hey guys i'm off the grid for august
probably sitting on the veranda with an
iced tea right now but in my fine state
of florida i spent a lot of time telling
you how the cities are falling apart and
most of them seem to be but not all of
them are it's a pretty amazing success
story we're not exactly sure why it's
happening we're going to try and find
out right now the city of miami
is on track for the lowest crime rate
since the 1930s
since al capone moved there
why what are they doing that no one else
is doing francis suarez is the mayor of
miami he joins us now mr mayor thanks so
much for coming on i wish we'd done this
story earlier i wasn't even aware of it
till today what exactly are you doing in
miami that
america's other cities are not doing
well i'm going to blow your mind away we
actually increase funding for police so
we have the most police officers we've
ever had in our history
we've also
lowered taxes to the lowest level in
recorded history which has prompted
tremendous growth we grew 12 percent i
think it's the second most uh in
recorded history as well we have a 1.4
percent unemployment we're the happiest
city in america and the healthiest city
in america so it turns out if people are
healthy they're happy
they're working they're not paying a lot
of taxes and they see
an increased police presence uh they
don't have a tendency to to commit
murder
and and that's what's uh been the miami
miracle story which is a huge contrast
to the washington nightmare story that
you've you know you've articulated
tonight and over the last few weeks
so there's this great video floating
around the internet i assume it's real
of the riots in the early summer of 2020
and they
people came to miami and decided they
were gonna riot and all these miami cops
come out come out of a patrol car and
say no it's our city we don't we're not
doing that here we're just not doing
that did you ever have meaningful riots
in miami
we really didn't because like you said
we drew the line uh in the sand and we
said you're not going to hurt people
you're not going to destroy property
that's something we're just not going to
tolerate in our city and so you know i
think the first night we had
some some issues but right away i think
it was pretty clear that we weren't
going to tolerate it we weren't going to
accept it and so whoever came in from
out of town obviously realized that
miami wasn't a place that was going to
accept that kind of behavior and left
and went to somewhere else to to create
havoc over there
what's so funny is that for a long time
beginning in
probably around 1980 for at least a
decade after miami was famous fairly or
not for crime it was a whole tv show
about it miami vice
is it kind of weird to be now famous for
being safe
you know i grew up in miami i was born
and raised there i was born in 1977 you
know in the 80s we had 300 plus
homicides right now and i knock on wood
here in the studio we are at uh 28 here
today
so from 300 plus uh to 28 and we're
hoping uh the trend continues for the
rest of the year and uh they're
literally we had to look back in our
archives to see when was the last time
we were ever that low and so like i said
you know it's really a a trusted and
true uh you know formula for success we
keep taxes low we keep people safe and
we lean into innovation to create
high-paying jobs it's a sort of the
miami story and it's something that
should be scaled across america
it's pretty incredible murders are the
one thing that are pretty easy to
measure so there's kind of no lying
about how many murders you have that's
why it's just no lie amazing
absolutely mr mayor thanks so much for
joining us francis squares of miami
thank you tucker
you